guys uh we're five days away you know
it's one of those things where the week
kind of ramps up slowly ramps up
gradually and then the next thing you
know we're uh we're at the game and it's
uh it's time to kick it off and see
what's gonna happen tomorrow what's the
craziest day of the week i mean when do
you think it really kicks it off here in
this room like tomorrow you think we're
gonna have a day where it goes crazy or
is it thursday wednesday is when it
starts to really crank up but but i when
i first started doing this friday was
the craziest day but then i think people
realized friday's the craziest day so
they started avoiding friday and it made
thursday the craziest day if that makes
any sense but thursday lately has been
the craziest day
you know the nuttiness starts when joe
montana appears on radio row
that's when you know that it's
officially a super bowl here's the
here's the true nuttiness eight years
ago
indianapolis height of tebow mania at
radio row
people brushing past joe montana
that was the craziest thing i've ever
seen i mean bumping into joe montana
pushing him out of the way to follow the
pied piper who is tim tebow oh my i
don't even know what to say to that
though those people are stupid i don't
know what else to say sorry it was a big
deal he was a big deal eight years ago
joe montana was a big deal longer ago
than that and uh
joe montana can you believe that tim
tebow
threw a touchdown pass to be the dick
lebeau coach defense in overtime yeah in
the great pittsburgh steelers right tim
tebow beat the pittsburgh steelers by
throwing a pass beat the great dick
lebeau troy polamalu right what in the
world is that out about walk off 80 yard
touchdown
catch and run by demurius thomas it was
a slant route it was and it was uh
it's almost like a kid whacking at a
pinata when tim tebow was throwing the
ball like every once in a while he would
he would nail the pinata yeah right sure
every once in a while most of the time
he's flailing around all over the place
but every once in a while can you
imagine if tim tebow were accurate
can you imagine well if he if he'd been
accurate i mean tim tebow would have
been i kept absolute phenomena yeah no
you're right it would have been a phenom
yeah it could have been a taste some
hill if he could throw like tasty hill
uh jimmy garoppolo the quarterback of
the san francisco 49ers has gotten a lot
of criticism and peter we were talking
about this yesterday he's not criticized
for what he's doing he's criticized for
what he's not doing and and this is such
a weird
vibe right they completely have
abandoned the passing game i think kyle
shanahan got freaked out by a couple of
near-misses from jimmy garoppolo in the
divisional round game against the
vikings so they decided screw it we're
just gonna run the ball and run the ball
until they stop us and nobody's been
able to stop them right the vikings
couldn't stop them 16 straight runs in
the second half of the division around
game
eight total passes 42 total runs in the
nfc championship and then so the
question becomes if they have to rely on
jimmy garoppolo can he do it peter look
uh and i know there was a lot of staunch
defense of jimmy garoppolo what do you
expect last night at media night
but look you have to ask the question
kyle shanahan is one of the most
brilliant
offensive play designers and play
callers
in the game today we're in the 100th
year of the nfl
and the most bizarre thing i've seen is
the san francisco 49ers getting to the
super bowl by being a 75 run team yeah
how in the world does that happen that
you're the 72 dolphins with kik and
zonka and mercury morris how in the
world does that happen today and that's
why in my opinion
look
if your quarterback has thrown 14 passes
in sick the last six quarters
it's a concern
it's a concern because if you put the
game on his shoulders which they may
well do sure they have put the game on
his shoulder several times this year and
it worked out swimmingly all i'm saying
is that can anybody really be positive
that if jimmy garoppolo throws it 38
times the 49ers are going to win no no
that's that's the you're right that's
the million-dollar question you know i
mean we've been talking about that all
year now i think the the other side of
this is okay yeah you know okay 14
throws the last six quarters you're
right it's really odd i think it's you
know the game just played out that way i
don't think shanahan thought oh i'm
gonna run for 300 yards on the packers
and all that too uh to your point though
i would imagine that shanahan is very
aware of that and man my guy hasn't
really gotten a rhythm since week 17 in
seattle in the passing game to where we
talked about a little last hour i think
they'll be probably an effort to get
them easy completions through the screen
game play action passes that are quick
passes right over the middle just like a
basketball player so he could see the
ball switch through the net a few times
you go okay i'm back in the flow but to
what you're saying yeah i don't know if
he throws it 38 times i would go they're
not going to win the game i guess that's
what i would basically look at right
like what's the number
of line of demarcation of throws to
where you guys would go oh that's not
good for the 49ers formula is it plus 30
throws is it 25. you think that's about
the number 25 then you're starting to go
oh they must be playing from behind or
they're not
dominating in the run game right
and i like your point the idea of
helping him build some confidence early
yeah some short passes controlled passes
simulated running plays basically but if
they can't stop the run i mean that's
the thing i i don't think kyle shanahan
is going to overcomplicate this no one
has been able to stop that running game
so they're going to run the ball and if
the chiefs can't stop it we will know
the moment raheem mostert scored on that
third and eight trap play
that yeah the nfc championship game was
over right because it's not like you can
adjust in the second half and all of a
sudden not get your ass kicked in the
running game right if you can't stop
them you can't stop them and you're not
stopped but you know what there are
other ways to work it how about the way
the kansas city chiefs stopped derek
henry i mean in the last 35 minutes of
the game he only had nine yards or eight
yards and the way that they stopped it
is long possessions
and basically
making sure that you had some long
yardage downs on second and third day
right and that is the way i think kansas
city will try to do this and look steve
spagnolo has a very good big game resume
he does going back to the giants really
frustrating tom brady with a bunch of
kawika mitchells yeah okay yeah and and
when i look at steve spagnolo i say
he's going to figure out some way and
and and can i also say this i'm not sure
it's going to be raheem moster it might
be tevin cooper it could be shanahan
rides the hot hands he does that's
exactly what he does and so he at the
start of the green bay packers game that
game i thought was going to be kevin
coleman yeah and and it it became a
monster game and now all of a sudden
most are last night at one point i say
oh my god raheem moster's got more
people around him than jimmy garoppolo
right
it's amazing what what what one game
really what three quarters
did for raheem mostert and so to me
i just think
this is one of the great things about
this super bowl
we don't know
and i'm not even sure right now that
kyle shanahan knows what he's going to
do in this game that's the cool thing
about this super bowl too you're right
we don't know there's really like a lot
of strength for strength weakness versus
weakness type match-ups that i think
really make it like awesome that way and
i think to speak to how awesome this
super bowl is all right we're sitting
here on a wednesday or tuesday sorry at
8 o'clock and we're breaking down
the eighth rated quarterback in football
i mean that's where we're looking at
like the weakness of a team so that's
how strong the team is really i think it
does give you a little bit of a like an
overlook to go damn yeah there's really
not a lot of weaknesses with either one
of these teams especially the 49ers to
just sit here and go we're talking about
a guy who's 27 and 13 as far as
touchdowns interceptions almost 4 000
yards you know quarterback rating only
behind patrick mahomes at number eight
and i understand the numbers don't say
all that but i just think it is funny i
think we've got a little overboard on
the
man can jimmy g handle this i don't know
we saw him go to new orleans and win a
shootout versus drew brees it wasn't but
but it wasn't the super bowl it wasn't i
understand that i get that i mean i get
it and it feels like a long time ago yes
when you look at the last six quarters
and when you accept the reality we were
there yeah we saw it we sensed it kyle
shannon got freaked out yeah by the
notion that jimmy g had some some close
calls
eric kendricks could have interceptions
definitely right in his hands so let's
just run the ball and we're going to run
the ball and 16 runs later they can't
stop him so against the packers we're
just going to run the ball and run the
ball we're going to get to the super
bowl we'll worry about the super bowl
when the super bowl comes there's got to
be guys in that locker room that are
thinking man if we can't run the ball
can can jimmy do this
how can you not wonder that if you are
one of the guys on the team isn't it
natural isn't it natural
for
the quarterback of the team who is a
very well-liked guy in that locker room
garoppolo
isn't it natural if there are questions
about him for sort of the tribe to close
ranks yes and for everyone to just
knee-jerk automatically say hey leave
our jimmy alone definitely you know they
so they're going to do that right even
though they're concerned yeah i bet they
are well i bet they are well the other
thing too i think you got to remember
here is within those conversations which
i'm sure they're very real like you're
right and guys are gonna close ranks but
within having confidence or not
confidence in jimmy garoppolo and i
would think there's confidence there you
know
is the fact you're i think they have
faith in shanahan that's the other thing
that i think they do i think they just
think kyle will figure out a way to get
him going and find some easy plays to
get him going to where he feels
confident and then we all feel confident
in him as well here's the shanahan
effect on the san francisco 49ers this i
asked joe staley
an hour after the nfc championship game
i said joe let me ask you
did you really think really that you'd
ever get to another super bowl and he
said no yeah i mean now that is raw and
honest and then after about three
seconds he said but
the first time kyle shanahan talked to
our team i thought
we might we might have a chance right
and he said
that was so impressive not because he's
mr uh after dinner speaker
but because he just looked us in the eye
and basically said all right
men you know i mean here's the way it's
gonna be and he totally took command of
that team at that time and i really
think that is the key they have faith in
him however it plays out he's got a plan
and it'll work and if the plan doesn't
work he'll move on to a plan that does
work yeah yeah and and that's look
they've been in every game they play
this year yep they they've they've only
had a few narrow losses in tough spots
and uh you know they're across the board
you take away patrick mahomes and jimmy
garoppolo the 49ers are the better team
yes they are patrick holmes narrows it
considering he's a huge 49ers at every
other position i i think so and you know
that's why i lean 49ers so far sitting
here on a tuesday i'm i'm picking them
because i'm going to go with the better
team but i am scared to death of the big
guy in the red jersey that's standing up
here which is number 15 patrick mahomes
because he is he's a magic man
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports